foreign
[Music]
bad attempts at making your answering
machine messages more jokey it's a
really cool visual that you got will to
draw all these roots but who has this
much paper at their house did Joyce pick
up a part-time job at Dunder Mifflin
[Music]
how exactly was this space even created
she didn't have a piece of paper to
connect the top piece to then how did
she know the picture at the bottom was
even in the right place taping up your
upside down art over a Jaws poster and
the more he spreads the more connected
to my field this sounds really serious
if only Joyce hadn't promised will she
wouldn't call a doctor if only there was
a doctor a few miles down the road that
specialized in the upside down if only
I'd stop talking like this earphone it's
like when you have a dream
and you can't remember it unless you
think really hard I typically find that
no amount of hard thinking will help me
recall a dream those memories have to be
triggered by something similar happening
during the day that reminds me of what I
dreamed the night before so here's a sin
for will trying to psychoanalyze the
situation when he doesn't even have a
medical license that's fraud William
fraud maybe all this is happening for a
reason Mike pulls the everything happens
for a reasonable and I can't help but
recall sitting in the courtroom trying
to explain why I was found naked in the
freezer at a Wendy's I ultimately played
the everything happens for a reason
strategy and while I didn't go to prison
I got three years probation in mild
cases of frostbite on unfortunate places
on my body so don't tell me this
reasoning Works Mike
oh man Hop's gonna go out like nedry and
Jurassic Park isn't he death by goop to
the face if they could repair the hole
that quickly why'd they wait until
Hopper collapse to do it shouldn't the
roots and Patch this up shortly after
Hopper punched a hole in their vein
making it sound like you're sucking up
the entire Atlantic Ocean through a
straw when you drink oh we only seem to
hang out when the world's about to end
you have no proof the world's about to
end you saw one Terror in reality that
the scientists seem to have contained
and that's it sure we all know about the
roots and tunnels under Hawkins but
Nancy doesn't did she read the script
when we weren't looking after everything
I'm just
I mean I thought my brother was dead my
mother was having a psychotic breakdown
and then we got attacked by monsters
from another dimension and almost died
sorry I wasn't there for you Nancy I'll
try to stop being so selfish
[Music]
I think he's going to die so glad the
writers chose to bring will back and
just make him the Lassie of season two
as we've said so many times we do not
need to see anyone throw up on screen
and then somehow the duffs make it worse
by having Hopper throw up blood waiting
until after you've been trapped in
poison to finally make a face covering
honestly it's a wonder hop doesn't die
in season two that's enough Erica
kids a lot of crazy happens in this
episode but honestly the biggest mystery
is how Erica has a plastic Mrs
Butterworth squeeze bottle in 1984. when
those didn't land on shelves until 1999.
I want to know more about the time
traveling syrup we can find her giving
her sobbing mother false hope the mighty
duxtons
Dustin who's never shown any physical
prowess whatsoever Wayne Gretzky's a
baby demogorgon into his basement
entrance several feet away I'm sorry you
ate my cat Dustin if you really want
Dart to forgive you you've got to give
it a little more oomph
[Music]
breaking and entering breathe sunflower
rainbow for 50 . whoa Elle's mother is a
winter soldier what a Twist I did not
see that coming conspiracy nut has a red
string bulletin board cliche watch the
attitude telling someone to watch their
attitude while giving them well attitude
you can keep things PG in here right
putting two teens in a private room and
expecting them to keep things PG would
you put a fox in a hen house and tell it
to keep things vegan I just needed a
safe place a safe place to what be
creepy Max would be the maddest and
maxius at TV sins
about
Vines nobody watches Vines anymore Joyce
we're all into Tick Tock now trying to
keep up now if you'll excuse me I have
some Tosh.0 reruns to watch on my TiVo
okay so the lines aren't roads
immediately forgetting that you were
just talking about the health of Will
and Joyce because you got excited about
a break in the game don't you get it
it's not a puzzle
it's a map but Joyce already knew it was
some sort of map and we knew it was some
sort of map so why is Bob's exclamation
look at
me is he with
hovering again you know what hop here's
12 sins for once again breathing in
poisonous air with no fabric over your
mouth do you want upside down particles
in your lungs because that's how you get
upside down particles in your lungs and
upside down ants Hopper was only able to
get the vine monsters to move away with
the fire since there's no fire anymore
why aren't they just closing back in on
him you tell me where you came from I
feel like the first question Becky
should be asking 11 is how the did
she get the chain lock to move and open
the door with her mind
[Music]
what the
knows but you can't pick your mom's nose
all right I'm 3.6 inches what do you got
please
please fights off she lobe is packing
anything less than nine inches there's
no need to be so modest Samwise Karen
where's Nancy expecting your wife to
know where your kids are instead of
taking an interest in parenting yourself
son of a you know you really no
help at all you know that Mr Wheeler
literally just told Dustin where Mike
and Nancy were how could he have been of
any more help choosing to smoke a
cigarette when you're having all kinds
of issues breathing normally even in the
80s smokers knew this wasn't a great
idea Hopper eventually survives this
music really complaining that someone is
about to play Billie Holiday stop
talking cutting off the nice lady who
made you lunch offered to take you in
and badly wants to communicate with her
brain damaged sister One Last Time Lucky
for 11 Mama's memories are being kind
enough to just give Elle the greatest
hits
yeah
Hopper also does nobody in this town
understand how dangerous it is to go
underground without a proper face
covering here's 30 more sins for all
these amateur spelunkers that don't know
what the they're doing you see
anything I mean in your now memories
referring to current knowledge as now
memories you're experiencing it
currently you're not remembering
anything just how sharp is Hopper's
pocket knife he cuts through that like a
box cutter through packing tape dude
Miss sharpen his blade at least once a
week or you know the writers do probably
that
man
that's the horrifying image my brain
will see when I wake up to pee at three
in the morning now mentally put
screaming will right next to that thing
from The Grudge
foreign
twice
you wanna have sex sure no Kelly
Clarkson when mom's mad at you
how do you make her not mad sing her
Ashanti nice and snappy washer in the
bathtub I have come here to chew bubble
gum and kick ass
there's no crying in baseball